Hey there, I'm Mario. I built pie in a
world of slop and this is a strategy, a
tragedy in three acts. Just to talk
about this real quick, bunch of people
on the internet gave me money for ad
space on my torso and all of that goes
to a charity. So yeah, thanks guys.
So act one building pi in the beginning
there was cloud code and was good right
we all got basically catnipped by that
thing and stopped sleeping um bunch of
stuff before that but code cloud code
was the one thing that kind of clicked
with me the most and to preface all of
this I love the cloud cloud team they're
are brilliant people talented super high
velocity so uh they also created the
entire game major props to them so this
is not a roast this is just me an old
man telling you why I stopped using
cloud code and built my own thing. Um in
2025 I started using cloud code in about
April I think thanks to Peter uh because
he told us the agents are working now
and back then it was simple and
predictable and fit my workflow but
eventually
the token madness got hold of them I
think and the team got bigger and they
started uh dog fooding that stuff and
build a lot of features a lot of
features I don't need which is fine I
can just ignore them but with velocity
and more features come more bucks and
that's mad because I used to work at
construction sites and if my hammer
breaks every day I'm getting really mad
and if my development tools break every
day I'm also getting mad. So there was
this it's just a running gag and here's
tar telling us that cloud code is now a
game engine and here's Mitchell from
Ghosty telling us no it's not and
eventually they fixed the flicker but
then other stuff broke and I think
they're now in the third iteration of a
2y renderer. Yeah but that's just a
symptom. The real problem is that my
context wasn't my context. Cloud code is
the thing that controls my context. And
behind my back, cloud code does things
uh to the context. So you have the
system prompt which changes on every
release, including the tool definitions.
They would remove tools, modify tools.
It's not good. They would insert system
reminders in the most oppoune place in
your context, telling the model, here's
some information. It may or may not be
relevant to what you're doing. That it
actually says it may or may not be
relevant what you're doing. And that
kind of confused the model and that kind
of broke my workflows.
On top of all that, there's zero
observability because that's how the
tool is constructed and I like knowing
what my agents are doing. There's zero
model choice which is obvious. It's the
native entropic uh harness. So it makes
sense for them to want you to use cloud,
right? And there's almost zero
extensibility and some of you might have
written some hooks for cloud code, but
I'm telling you the number of hooks and
the depth of those hooks is very
shallow. Um, and every time a hook
triggers, what actually happens is a new
process gets spawned. Basically, the
command you specified for the hook to be
executed. And I don't find that
specifically efficient. So, I uh took a
step back and looked around for
alternatives. And I'd like to especially
call out AMP and factory droid, the
Porsche and Lamborghini of coding agent
harnesses. So, if you can afford them,
please use them. They're at the
frontier. They're really good, and the
teams are fantastic. And there's a bunch
of other options. And I have history in
OSS. So naturally I kind of gravitated
towards open code and again brilliant
team super high execution velocity and
they don't sell you hype they sell you
tools that work for the most part. I
started looking under the hood of open
code uh with respect to context handling
as well because that's the most
important part for me and I found a
bunch of things like given some
conditions open code would just uh prune
tool output after a specific minimum
amount of tokens and that basically
lobomizes the model. Uh there's also LSP
server support which means every time
your model is calling the edit tool open
code goes to the LSP server that's
connected asks are there any errors and
if so injects that as part of the edit
tool uh result which is bad because
think about how you add editing code
you're not writing a line of code
checking the errors writing the next
line checking the errors you don't do
that you finish your work and then you
check the errors this confuses the model
there's a bunch of other things like
storing individual messages of a session
in a JSON file. Each me message is a
JSON file on disk. Uh there was this and
this happens to all of us. No, no claim
there. But it's not great if by default
a server spins up, course headers are
set in such a way that any website you
open in your browser can now access your
open code server. That's yeah, and
entirely unrelated to all of this, I
started looking into benchmarks for
coding agent harnesses and found
terminal bench um which is a pretty good
benchmark all things considered. And the
funny part about it is that it's the
most minimal kind of thing you can think
of. All it gives the model is a tool to
send keystrokes to to a T-Max session
and read the output of that T-Max
session. There's no file tools, no sub
agents, none of that stuff. And it's one
of the best performing harnesses in the
leaderboard. Here's the leaderboard from
December 2025. irrespective of model
family terminal scores higher mostly
high even higher than the native harness
of that model. So what does that tell
us? A form two thesis is we are in the
[\h__\h] around and find out phase of coding
agents and their current form is not
their final form right. So second thesis
is we need better ways to [\h__\h] around
and for me that means self modifying
malleable agents things that the agent
itself can modify and I can modify
depending on my workflow. So I stripped
away all the things built a minimal core
but made it super extensible and made it
so that the agent can modify itself
with some creature comforts. It's not
entirely bare bones. Uh so that's PI.
It's an agent that adapts to your
workflow instead of the other way
around. It comes with four packages. Uh
an AI package that's basically just an
abstraction across providers and context
handoff between providers. An agent core
uh which is just a while loop and the
tool calling. A bespoke toy framework. I
come out of game development. So I built
a thing that actually doesn't flicker
too much. And the coding agent itself.
Here's Pi's system prompt.
That's it. Eventually the industry
created a new standard called skills
which is basically just markdown files.
So we added that as well. and that needs
to go in a system prompt. So, be
crouchingly, we had to add a couple more
lines. And finally, here's the magic
that makes Pi able to modify itself. We
ship the documentation which was
handcrafted by me and an agent. Um, and
code examples of extensions,
and all we need to do for the agent to
modify itself is tell it, here's the
documentation. Here's some code that
shows you how to modify yourself by
writing extensions.
It comes with four tools. That's all it
has. Retrate, edit, mesh. Here's the
tool definitions. Don't read the the
text. Just look at the size.
That's it. Here's what happens when you
start a new session in one of these
tools.
So the thing is the models are actually
reinforcement trained up to a wazoo. So
they know what a coding agent is because
a coding agent harness is basically what
they're being trained when they are
post-trained. You don't need 10,000
tokens to tell them you're a coding
agent. They know because they are coding
agents. No, PI is also YOL by default
because my security needs are different
than yours. And I don't think a little
dialogue that pops up every now every
time you call bash asking you to approve
is a smart security uh uh mechanism. So
instead I give you so much rope that you
can build anything that's fit for your
specific security needs. There's also
stuff that's not built in. I'm a he
because this is how I do it. But if you
don't like that then you just ask Pi to
build you sub agent support or plan mode
or MCP support whatever you need.
Extensibility comes with a bunch of
table stakes and then with the
extensions itself and extensions imply
are just TypeScript modules. In the
simplest case a TypeScript file on disk.
You point PI at that. Here's an
extension loaded as part of the harness.
And with that you get a basically an
extension API that lets you hook into
everything and define stuff for the
harness to expose to the to the model.
And that includes tools uh slashcomand
shortcuts. You can listen in on any kind
of event and react and then save state
in the session that's optionally
provided to the agent as well or stored
there for tools that analyze sessions as
part of your organizational workflows.
You can do custom compaction, custom
providers and you have full control over
the tool. So you can modify everything
in PI and you can then bundle all of
that up and put it on mpm or on GitHub
because I think we don't need to
reinvent another bunch of silos called
marketplaces. We already have package
manage managers and all of that hot
reloads. So if you develop an extension
for pi, you do so in the session and you
hot reload the changes and see the the
effects of that immediately which is
very great and it's also game
development thing is in game development
you want high very low iteration uh
speeds and that's great. So a couple of
examples cloud or anthropic ships the
slash by the way which lets you talk to
the agent why goes on its main quest. I
posted this little prompt on Twitter
jokingly and somebody build it in five
minutes with more features and they
didn't have to fork a clone pie. They
just let the agent write the extension
based on the prompt. Here's Nico. He's
one of the most prolific uh extension
writers. I don't know what the [\h__\h] is
going on here. It's a chat room for all
of his Pi agents and they talk with each
other. I would never use this, but all
of this is custom including the UI. or
you can play NES games or you can play
Doom.
And there's a bunch of other examples
I'm not going to talk about. So, how do
you build a PI extension? You don't. You
tell Pi to build it for you based on
your specifications. And then you just
iterate with it on that and hot reload
during the session. I'm going to skip
that example as well. And if you don't
like building things yourself, and I
hope you do like building things
yourself, but if you don't, you can look
on MPM or our little search uh interface
on top of MPM to find packages for sub
agents, MCP, and so on. So, does it
actually work? Well, here's the terminal
bench leaderboard from October before Pi
had compaction. I added that for Peter's
claw thingy. It scored sixth place.
Uh, but none of this is actually about
Pi. If you want to retake, I I basically
want you to retake control of your tools
and workflows. So build your own. Um and
if you want to know more about pi and
openclaw, go to this talk please. Yeah.
And then eventually Peter happened. He
put pi inside of open claw as its aentic
core which meant my open source project
became the target of a lot of openclaw
instances unbeknownst to their users. So
this is act 2 oss in the age of
clankers. Clankers are destroying oss.
Here's tal draw. They closed down the
issue on pull request tracker. Here's
open clause uh trackers. Here's mine.
Half of that is open source instances
who post garbage. So I started to rage
against the clankers.
Um if you send a pull request, it gets
autoclosed with a comment that asks you
to please write a nice issue in your
human voice, no longer than a screen
worth of text. And if I see that I write
looks good to me and your account name
gets put in a file in the repository and
the next time you send a pull request,
it's let through. Clankers don't read
that comment. They don't go back once
they posted a pull request. So that's a
perfect filter. Uh Mitchell eventually
turned it into vouch. Here's a clanker.
Uh I also labeled them. If you had
interactions with openclaw, your issues
get dep prioritized. I also built tools
where I embed uh issues and pull request
texts into 3D space. So I see clusters
of issues. Uh I also invented OSS
vacation. I just close the tracker
whenever I want. So I have my life back.
So does this work? Yes, sort of.
Which leads me to act three. Slow the
[\h__\h] down. Everything's broken.
And then there's people that say, "Our
product's been 100% built by agents."
Yes, we know it [\h__\h] sucks now.
Congratulations.
And I'm hearing this from my peers and
this is entirely unhealthy.
Um, so here's how we should not work
with agents and why, at least in my
opinion. I wrote this on my blog a while
ago, but the basic is this. We're having
armory of agents and you're using beats
on been and you don't know that it's
basically uninstallable malware and
entropic build a C compiler that kind of
works but actually doesn't and we're
hoping the next generation of models
will fix it and here is Perso building a
browser and that's also super [\h__\h]
broken but the next generation will fix
it and SAS is dead software solved in
six months and my grandma just built
herself a Spotify with her open claw
come on people so agents are actually
combounding boooos which is my word for
errors with serial learning and No
bottlenecks and uh delayed pain. The
delayed pain is for you. Here's your
code base on a human on one agent and 10
agents. How much of the agent code can
you review? Here's the same codebase but
expressed in number of boooos per day.
How much of those boooos do you think
you'll find? Then you say, "Oh, I have a
review agent. Let me introduce you to
the wonderful world of the Oro." Doesn't
work. It catches some issues. Um the
problem is that agents and merchants
have learned complexity. Where did they
learn that complexity from? From the
internet. What's on the internet? All
our old garbage code. There are some
pearls on the internet, really
well-designed systems, but 90% of code
on the internet is our old garbage. And
that's what the models learn from. And
every decision of an agent is local,
especially if the codebase is so big
that it doesn't fit into its context.
And if you let it go wild and add
abstractions everywhere that are
intertwined. Um, so that leads to lots
of abstractions and duplication and
backwards compatibility. Who has seen
that in the output of their agent? It's
[\h__\h] annoying or defense in depth. So
yeah, you get enterprise grade
complexity within two weeks with just
two humans and 10 agents.
Congratulations.
And then you say, but my detailed spec.
Yes, sure. You know what we call a
sufficiently detailed spec? It's a
program.
So if you leave blanks in your spec,
what do you think happens? How does the
model fill in the blanks? And with what
does it fill that in? It fills it in
with the garbage that it learned on the
internet from our old code, which is
garbage to mediocre. And then you say,
but humans also, yes, humans are
horrible, fail failable beings, but they
can learn and they are bottlenecks.
There's only so many boooos they can add
to your code base on a daily basis. And
humans feel pain, which is a very
interesting property because humans hate
pain. And once there's too much pain,
the human has a bunch of options. It can
quit their job. It can uh blame somebody
else and make them fix it or everybody
bands together and starts refactoring
the [\h__\h] out of the garbage codebase,
right? Agents will happily keep [\h__\h]
into your codebase.
And now your agents MD and super complex
memory systems will not save you. agents
don't learn the way we learn.
Those are my most most beloved people. I
don't even read the code anymore.
Congratulations. Something is broken and
your users are screaming. So, who you
going to call? Not yourself because you
haven't read the code. So, you're
relying on your agents, but they are now
also overwhelmed because the codebase is
so humongous that there's absolutely
zero chance they can get all the context
they need to fix the issues. And long
context windows are a heck, as most of
you will find out this year. as
everybody's switching to 1 million
tokens context windows and agentic
search is also failing.
So the agent patches locally and [\h__\h]
[\h__\h] up globally. If you see this in
your codebase, you're [\h__\h]
So you cannot trust your codebase
anymore and also not your test because
your agent wrote your test. So good
game. So here's how I think we should
work. Um there's a bunch of properties
for good agent tasks. That means scope.
If you can scope it in such a way that
the agent is guaranteed to find all the
things it needs to find to do a good
job, you're done. That means modularize
your codebase. If you can give it a
function to evaluate how well it did the
job, even better. Hill climbing, auto
research. Uh, anything non-m mission
critical, let it wipe. Boring stuff, let
it wipe. Reproduction cases for user
issues, which are usually only partial
in information, perfect. I don't spend
any mornings anymore doing that. Or if
you don't have a human near you, rubber
duck. So, lots of tasks you can use them
for and save time. At the end of that,
you evaluate. You take what's
reasonable. Most of it isn't. And then
finalize. My final slide, more or less,
slow the [\h__\h] down. Think about what
you're building and why. And don't just
build because your agent can do it. Now,
that's stupid. Uh, learn to say no. This
is your most valuable uh capability at
the moment. Fewer features, but the ones
that matter. And then use your agents to
polish the [\h__\h] out of that. Enlighten
your users, not your uh token maxing
desires. Get the amount of generated
code uh that you need to review.
And non-critical code, sure, wipe slop
ahead. Critical code, read every [\h__\h]
line. See the keynote after me for more
info on that. So, how do you know what's
critical? Any guesses?
Well, you read the [\h__\h] code. Uh, if
you do anything important, write it by
hand. You can use a clanker to help you
with that, but don't let it make the
decisions for you because we've learned
all the decisions it makes are learned
from the internet. And that friction is
the thing that builds the understanding
of the system in your head, which is
important. And it's also where you learn
new things. And all of this requires
discipline and agency. And all of this
still requires humans. Thank you.